Jason is with us Jason's in Fayetteville
Arkansas hi Jason how are you I'm great
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up
well I my wife and I are former opiate
addicts we've been in recovery now for
three years
and you know we've made big advances
compared to where we were a couple years
ago in our lives but I'm starting to see
a lot further into the future than I
used to and I'm looking for some
motivation I we've kind of fell into a
slump where I think especially my wife
sees things is we're not doing as bad as
we used to so where we are today is okay
you know and so I'm looking for a way to
get on the same page not only
financially but just in our life in
general and start really moving forward
yeah good for you congratulations man
you fought a tough fight yeah it's been
a long road and you know what like I
said we've come a long way but I want so
much more for her I want so much more
for my children and we're scratching and
clawing every step of the way but some
days it just feels like life has its way
of getting in the way of everything we
try to do you know amen amen having this
all of us and you have come a long way I
mean you've come from the brink of death
really because that's yeah the road you
were on to living life and now you're
trying to live life well and that's the
negative so how old are you I'm 32 years
old I'll be 33 in August my wife's 31
and we've got a couple of daughters and
I say again how old are they
11 and 8 okay and what's your household
income we're right at about 60 good what
do you do for a living I'm a steel
erector by trade and then also remodel
houses part-time and a little bit
anything else I can do to get extra
income in mowing brush Hoggins kind of
depends on the season you know don't you
okay
well I know a couple things about you
too from your story already what one is
your fighters and you've seen the bottom
and so you know what it looks like and
you don't ever want to go there again
and the second thing I know about you is
your hard workers you're not afraid of
hard work
and what you are saying is I want all of
this to amount to something breaking
even and okay yeah and I agree with you
I think you're right and truthfully
coming out of what you all have come out
of she may be a little bit emotionally
tired from fighting the last three years
to get to where you are you know yes sir
and it's like you run a little bit out
of gas and so what you've got to do is
look in what I have to do and what
anybody has to do when we look into the
future the Bible says where there is no
vision the people perish you die from a
lack of vision and it doesn't mean
physically you die can mean that but
what it means is you don't become what
you should have become and that's what
you're talking about exactly and so you
you see that there's a possibility of
becoming something and and so what I
think you guys need to do is to sit down
and dream together about what life would
be like if not just if we were clean for
three years but if we were clean for 23
years and we were wealthy
yes sir and in other words you need a
y-you need a dream that you detail out
and say it would be worth kicking butt
and taking names to get to this dream
and then Chris Hogan and his book retire
inspired says you need to dream an HD
high-definition dreams not vague Oh
someday I'd like to have some money
that's vague right but instead it's like
I want a house that is two stories with
white columns on a hill on 14.3 acres I
just made all that up that only that
it's not necessarily yours I just made
that up but whatever your dream is my
point is paint the detail out where you
both can see the detail
and you both that makes you smile that
makes your heart rate change that makes
you get excited that makes you willing
to pay a price that's how you got dry
yes sir
you saw a vision clearly that life would
be good if you could get there am I
wrong no not at all it's the same thing
when you're setting goals for your
career when you're setting goals for
your wealth-building when you're setting
goals for your marriage in the future
whatever it is you're working on paint
it out in high definition HD in detail
here's exactly where we're doing we're
getting ready to move into a new
building a new office building for our
company and when we got ready to start
work on that which bought the ground
four years ago we broke ground on the
building two years ago and we're going
to move in and July and it's two hundred
and twenty three thousand square feet so
it's a massive building with nine
bazillion details but I tell you what
every single one of those details were
on paper before there was a building
called a blueprint mm-hmm we didn't go
hey let's put a building over there you
know
no detailed line-by-line blueprint as
thick as a freaking phonebook to build
something like that and that's a HD
dream that's a high-definition dream and
then the weird thing is you know that
building came up and it looks just like
that blueprint and that weird that's
what happened as what happens to your
life man that's what happens to your
life so HD dreaming and hold on I want
to be part of your recovery I'm so proud
of you all you raising some kids you
stayed married you didn't kill yourself
you got dry man I want to be part of
your story you're awesome